at the University of New Mexico native
American High School seniors from all
around the state are spending a day
learning about college life
seventeen-year-old Jay John's family
wants him to succeed is it exciting for
you to be here today yeah
um this is actually the school I won I'm
planning on attending but across the U.S
shockingly few indigenous young people
make it to College Nationwide just 19
percent of Native Americans aged 18 to
24 are enrolled in college compared to
41 percent of the overall population
only 16 percent attain a bachelor's
degree or higher Native Americans are
among the poorest populations in the U.S
and college tuition is expensive another
factor is the century-long history of
U.S government-run boarding schools
which are now widely considered
instruments of cultural destruction
education was used to colonize
indigenous people in the United States
and so many have very bad memories of
Education as being a tool for extinction
along with the excitement of attending
college many Native American students
experience Jitters and a level of
anxiety over leaving their tight-knit
communities and families behind for the
first time Jay John is somewhat nervous
growing up like on the reservation you
know you have your grandma close like
half a mile away you have your uncles
and your aunties and you know you have a
lot of siblings when you leave and
you're alone and that's pretty tough
isolation took a toll on Raven Long Wolf
Alcott I was very depressed and anxious
and I think for the first time in my
life I was like
really challenged mentally and
spiritually she got through the crisis
and now hopes to use her Environmental
Science Education to help her people
many other young Native Americans would
like to give back to if there was a
better support system for them to attend
college and graduate right now there
isn't Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera
Albuquerque New Mexico